i'm so bloated and i'm like why can't i
why can't i feel good about my body
guilt free snacks i hate that term
[Music]
yeah
this is not a 60-day journey hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we are back with part six of our
review of jaclyn hill's weight loss
journey but first let me tell you about
my sponsor billbar so filming time in my
house means snack time and i love that i
also love that i get to take you guys
along with me for my little morning
gnosh here
but these bars are unlike any other
protein bar that i've tried because they
actually taste
like a candy bar no chalky powdery mealy
texture here and there are so many fun
flavors and speaking of fun
let me show you my favorite of all time
oh
the cookie dough chunk doesn't get more
fun than cookie dough
quote me on that quote me on that i
actually stole that quote from my
four-year-old son i got a full box of
fun here folks
and this this is my fav
15 grams of protein
like actual chunks of cookie dough
[Music]
there is a raver going on right here in
my body mmm every time i taste cookie
dough bar so good
this is a covet safe party over here
okay and you know what i say about the
zero guilt thing unless you stole them
from a baby all foods are zero guilt so
these are one of my go-to bedtime snacks
i love them or i use them and i put them
on oatmeal to like bump up the satiety
factor and turn that oatmeal into a
hunger crushing combo so if you want to
give these a try check out the link in
my description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
okay so we are back once again to
revisit jacqueline's weight loss journey
but if you missed my most recent video
you can check that out right here today
you'll be taking a look at jaclyn's
december 7th video
am i quitting and you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are new here
please do not forget to subscribe
to this channel and ring that bell also
follow me over on tick tock and
instagram at abby's kitchen for more
great myth busting information and
videos all right folks
well let's get into it number one
question i've been getting is am i
quitting this whole jaclyn's journey
series on my channel and the answer is
absolutely hell no i am not quitting but
i am taking a quick little break that's
why i have not uploaded that is some
expert clickbait right there this is
kind of why i don't think having a
weight loss series is particularly
helpful you know we might as well just
label this series as
life because manipulating or maintaining
weight is not a 60-day journey it's a
life journey it's just life the journey
is life
i started going back to therapy when it
comes to my journey i personally in this
in this moment i am focused 100 on my
mental health okay if you recall the
last time we caught up with jacqueline
she mentioned deciding to go back to
therapy to address her anxiety and
depression so i am glad to hear that
she's remained committed to putting her
mental health first and that she's
taking a pause on the intentional weight
loss especially since we know that
weight loss or gain is rarely just about
the food but rather it's often related
to mental health issues at its core and
for folks who specifically struggle with
body image issues extreme shifts in
weight can further challenge mental
health which ultimately becomes a
vicious cycle so in jaclyn's case
putting the focus on her emotional
well-being is likely the best thing she
can do for her health i am currently at
the exact same weight that i was last
time you guys saw me here on camera
which i'm really really happy about
because i lost i think 12 pounds i got
down to 170 and then i just like
went out of town and ate so much and i
went up to 172 and i've just been
sitting at 172 now for a while for a
couple of weeks since you guys saw me
last so hearing jaclyn discuss her
happiness and satisfaction with her
weight loss is a complete 180 from how
she was feeling in her previous video
and i am here for it if you recall when
jaclyn initially experienced the
two-pound jump in her weight it
triggered an intense emotional spiral
which led to an all-or-nothing last
supper episode but now we're seeing her
reframe and accept her achievements with
gratitude and pride and that may be a
sign that she's actually doing some
great work in therapy these past few
months so i'm really happy to see that
i've learned how to make healthier
decisions where i'm not losing and i'm
also not gaining you know what i'm
saying which i feel like is pretty good
because before i was just gaining gain
and gain because i was just like eating
whatever i wanted so it sounds like
jaclyn is settling into her set point
where maintaining her weight is more
effortless and maybe even intuitive
maybe i get asked a lot about setpoint
weight and while there are a lot of
theories floating around out there it
seems likely that we have basically like
a weight range where our bodies are just
most comfortable we can float within
this range with relative ease if we're
listening to our body but when we start
to defy it through extreme diets that's
when we find ourselves on the outskirts
and that seems to be what jaclyn
experienced in the wake of her very
restrictive diet she gained because she
was eating whatever she wanted as we
would expect one to do when faced with
extreme restriction and denial it may
take time to accept her natural body at
the weight that it's at now which may
actually be her healthy happy weight but
doing so may be the key to preventing
her set point from shifting further up i
have learned
not to eat late at night because it is
not good for me in any way shape or form
i wake up not feeling as well i'm so
bloated like i said crap all around not
to mention i feel like when you eat late
at night like that just literally stores
fat and i used to do that i would like
eat chips or whatever cheese and
crackers and then go to sleep 20 minutes
later and give me so much acid reflux
and digestion so i've stopped doing that
okay so let's debunk this myth shall we
so the idea that eating at night causes
weight gain comes from animal studies
suggesting that mice would gain weight
when they ate in opposition to their
circadian rhythms but friendly reminder
folks that we are not mice we are humans
and human research tells a slightly
different story now i've discussed this
in more detail in my videos on
intermittent fasting but while we do see
some benefits of fasting for metabolic
flexibility and we also know that there
are some metabolic and glucose
regulation benefits to eating in line
with our circadian rhythm we also know
that all of this
ultimately gets overruled when calories
come into play if you're eating in a
caloric surplus it doesn't matter if you
ate the meal at 10 a.m or 10 p.m the
excess calories from that food will be
stored this also means that if you
restrict or limit your calories all day
long only to overeat in a caloric
surplus at night you'll gain weight
not because you had midnight mickey d's
but because you ate beyond your needs
and ultimately any overeating at any
time of day can potentially result in
those bloating acid reflux and
indigestion symptoms that jaclyn is
talking about so my tip is to aim to eat
regular balanced meals throughout the
day for more even energy levels and
better digestion through the holidays my
plan is just to maintain my current
weight i'm not trying to lose weight i'm
also not trying to gain weight i just
want to maintain my weight to the
holidays and then once the holidays are
over that's when i'm going to go back
into like all right we gotta like pump
it into high gear and go into more like
weight loss mode and i'm like why can't
i why can't i feel good about my body if
they can feel good about theirs and at
the end of the day i just don't i just
don't i don't like the way it feels uh
yes the classic new year new me weight
loss pledge new year
new me
hi there welcome to park place
mcdonald's now despite the constant
promise that this journey isn't about
weight loss but rather about feeling
good we seem to see it come back to the
scale an awful lot and based on jaclyn's
past experience with the scale i am
worried that this is just going to
trigger disappointment deprivation
extreme restriction and ultimately
chaotic emotional eating that further
sabotages her goals so i would still
love to see jacqueline start focusing on
non-weight related health behaviors
while exploring non-food coping
strategies in therapy i'm gonna jump
into the snack portion now and show you
guys things i have been loving like
guilt-free snacks i hate that term
because it's like if you want to eat a
bag of doritos eat it and don't feel
guilty who cares do you but also the
kind of snacks where it's like you're
not going to feel
nasty afterwards they're not going to
feel bloated and gross is anyone
familiar with the old phrase what the
actual
does that mean i mean i am getting a lot
of mixed messages and if i can't make
sense of them i'm not sure how her
followers could be expected to either
first of all if you don't believe in
snacks inducing guilt then don't kick
off the section of the video calling
them guilt-free snap if you hate the
term then don't use it don't add to the
acceptance of that mentality second i
think anyone who's watched jaclyn's
journey has become privy to her own
propensity for emotionally fueled food
language so she has a history of
expressing guilt for her food choices
i'm literally sitting here eating pizza
this is i feel like the world's biggest
failure as far as my journey goes
i ate like i drank like i feel like i'm
ready to go home and i'm really excited
to hear her making an effort to
acknowledge this problematic language
pattern and to shift to a more neutral
way of discussing food but i would say
that calling out foods for how nasty or
gross they make you feel isn't exactly a
gentle approach either it's not unlike
the common diet industry's attempt to
rebrand itself away from explicit weight
loss diets to wellness or calling belly
fat instead bloat and again i don't
think jaclyn's trying to be sneaky here
she's just as engrossed in this culture
as you and i are but i bring this up to
help you all recognize this as still die
culture talking and to remind you that
you know eating pizza or doritos doesn't
need to make you feel nasty and on the
flip side drinking celery juice doesn't
necessarily make you feel clean we need
to learn how to collect that data for
ourselves and hey you know sometimes a
handful of chips just hits right
but i don't want to torture myself so i
need to snack so let's talk about some
of my favorite snacks that don't make me
feel like crap that don't bloat me and
are low in calories agreed no need to
torture yourself and skip the snack
but i want to remind you that snacks
don't have to be locale to
not bloat or make one feel like crap
locale shouldn't be a prerequisite for a
feel-good snack in fact if you watch my
videos on bloating here and here you'll
know that low-calorie snacks can often
be the cause of bloating by means of
adding excess air fiber or other
bloating additives to the gut awful
marcona almonds they are so crunchy
they're so salty and so truffle now keep
in mind if you eat a lot of nuts they
are fattening so they're also good fats
so i will eat just like a small handful
it just like feels good it holds you
over so yes jaclyn is correct in saying
that almonds like any nut are
calorically dense but you are also
getting a ton of nutritional bang for
your buck nuts are a built-in hunger
crushing combo with healthy fats protein
and fiber and i like that she described
them in morally neutral terms like
crunchy salty and satisfying rather than
cheat or bad or clean another thing this
right here tabouleh salad guilt-free
snack i will eat it with a fork like
this or what i will do we'll get some
cream cheese regular or chive and onion
then i'll grab one of these wraps i will
just put some cream cheese on one of
these wraps i'll light them out i'll
take a bunch of tabouli salad i'll put
it on top i always wrap it up and eat it
like a burrito again another guilt-free
slip but i also get that it takes a lot
of time to unlearn some of that deeply
ingrained language but i do love that
we've got fiber from the salad and the
wrap and some fat from the cream cheese
i mean i'd probably add in a little
extra protein
like some canned chickpeas or leftover
chicken in there but otherwise i would
say this is an easy satisfying mini meal
first things first right here
hummus with the chickpea crackers you
guys so freaking good and then obviously
you can do celery you can do cucumbers
you can do pepper bell pepper these
snacks are a huge upgrade from the
cucumbers with soy sauce situation we
saw in an earlier episode so hummus to
me is a built-in hunger crushing combo
and paired with the extra veggies and
crackers it's definitely a satisfying
snack as for the rest of her snacks
jaclyn shares a bunch of low-calorie
chip alternatives that still provide
that satisfying crunch and flavor that
she so much enjoys so for example things
like kale chips veggie chips popcorn
popcorn chips tortilla chips and some
pea and chickpea crisps and while these
are all great snacks for satisfying that
crunch mouth hunger if we wanted them to
keep us satiated longer we could turn
them into hunger crushing combos so for
example since jaclyn already enjoys beef
jerky and pistachios she could combine
them all together in one bowl and create
my hunger crushing combo popcorn mix
jacqueline also loves to meal prep
hard-boiled eggs to enjoy as an easy
grab-and-go snack during the week and
while eggs on their own are a great
source of protein and fats if we wanted
to give them the hunger crushing combo
treatment she could combine them with
the olives that she has in her fridge
for some healthy fats in there we love a
good carb as well as some different
kinds of veggies or crackers or the
tabouli salad for an extra fiber boost
lastly i love that she is embracing
snacks with more protein and fiber like
these roasted chickpeas but to make them
a little more fun and exciting she could
make my roasted chickpea hunger crushing
combo snack by combining them with a
side of guacamole for some healthy fats
or some raw veggies for extra fiber and
crunch so with all that said this has
certainly been a journey and while i
think that jaclyn expected this to be a
neat and tidy 60 day series weight loss
efforts are always messy as
my hope for jaclyn is that she continues
to focus on her mental health and
well-being and gives herself the grace
and patience to circle back on the food
piece when it feels supportive to her so
on that note that is all that i have for
you guys today thank you again to
buildbar for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
other videos that you guys want to see
me review subscribe to the channel and
i'll see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]